Michael go good life was this a
deliberate echo of the 80s or 70s sitcom
I don't think it was no I don't think
that anyone was channeling their energy
on Edmund or Bob Lobby I think that the
whole point of talking about the good
life was to emphasize that the
sacrifices that the countries made over
the course of the last five years in
order to get the economic recovery that
were now enjoying those sacrifices can
now translate if we stick with David
Cameron as our prime minister into a
genuinely good life for citizens in this
country the chance to have their
children better educated the chance to
have a home of their own the chance to
enjoy security and dignity and well
let's talk about we're just hearing
their their views on this extent of the
right to buy and 1.2 million people
apparently possibly eligible to buy
their home but all again those buy their
homes it's not going to create any more
new heads is it yes it is actually I
mean first of all I don't think there's
anything wrong with people wanting to
buy their own homes I presume that David
Orr owns his home or I but I mean
there's nothing wrong with the aim I
mean we're told we need what is it
240,000 new homes a year this isn't
going to generate those yes it will
because the 4.5 billion pounds that
we're taking from making sure that
council properties in the top third of
values are are sold and that the
receipts are then invested is different
from the right by scheme you implemented
over the last five years which has only
replaced
half of the housing stock that's been
sold two things I'd say the first thing
is that there are some of the cloth or
--'tis that have been like ODS and it
certainly we will make sure that local
authorities if they do not spend the
money that they've acquired from selling
properties in order to replace them we
will ensure housing work they haven't
been no idea handling replaced on a
one-to-one basis no there are some local
authorities that have been records but
but we have the power and we will ledge
that when we have these also is it also
is it anybody's but before showing in
Paris ins yeah I think it's important to
recognize that we built 217,000
affordable homes in the lifetime of this
polymer which is considerably more than
labor every one but it's certainly not
240,000 a year is it no but we're going
to increase the number of houses that we
build in role because the 4.5 billion
pounds which is liberated will enable
local authorities not only to match
the houses that are sold on a
like-for-like basis and also to help
people in the house actually the
governor knew it supported them to sell
their housing stock at below market
prices if I could finish my council
table is money not more no they will
have just enough money in order to
ensure that they can replace the housing
stock because many of these properties
the top third of those which they have
at the moment are capable of be settled
for hundreds of thousands exactly so
they sell council urns properly it sells
it for below market price to rich people
because the only people can afford those
properties of rich people you then give
a hundred thousand pounds to someone who
happens to live in the Housing
Association policy it's not logic it's
bribes that's all it is and it's private
little people oh you and your own house
I'm sure Adam so why is it is it bribery
or somehow immoral to encourage people
to earn their in homes
let me answer your first point but you
have it no yeah well you know what no
one offered me a hundred thousand do no
one offered me a hundred thousand pounds
of exchange my vote which is what you're
doing in this no certainly not doing
that but it's lovely well could you
100,000 pounds in order to cool off
stick with David Cameron if you live in
one of these homes you had one hundred
thousand pounds off the off the value of
your property that's what you're doing
yes and it's quite right that people
should have the job my point is it's not
generating housing and we have a housing
shortage we have large number of
homeless people in this my point is that
it will because not only will create the
money for local authorities to match
like for like an affordable home for
every council human soul it will also
generate a two hundred fifty million
pounds every year to take brownfield
land which is currently inappropriate
for building back into use and that will
create more homes again something that
it supports in the last five years but
it hasn't happened well you you can't
have your cake and eat it you can't
simultaneously say that this is a bribe
but all I know that also that it's right
that we surely know but mine is my
conscience the message today was let me
finish the job and every camera hasn't
started it in terms of actually building
affordable housing and providing people
with housing I over in this interview I
mentioned the number of affordable homes
is built yeah and as we said you said
will you said two hundred seventeen
thousand Oh to five years yes and I said
to you the general agreement is we need
over
a million a year yes so that'd be 1.5
mil yeah
and we're going to put more as a result
of making sure that we liberate the
money which is currently tied up one of
the things that we wanted to do and
which we've announced today that we will
do is to make sure that we can compel
the authorities to sell these boxes one
of the reasons that we weren't able to
do so is because the Liberal Democrats
vetoed that bottle and one of the
problems in your questioning is that the
premises that we had a majority do exalt
let's move on to another liberal
Democrat policy raising the tax
threshold what is the point of taking
and well put it but quite simply David
Cameron wasn't being honest was he when
he said we could take people on minimum
wage out of the tax net fine because the
average person on minimum wage works 43
hours a week he would only take people
out of the tax net her working 30 hours
a week are you not working full-time so
to say we're going to take people
minimum wage after tax net it's not true
is it well it is true
no not Moute as I say the average person
on minimum wage yes will still pay tax
work they did we specify the don't be 30
hours well is it's I think if you look
at a promise you say someone on minimum
wage won't have to pay income tax and
you find that the average person on
minimum wage will have to pay income tax
because they work 43 hours a week people
might think that's a bit of a con
well the promise is there isn't it that
it's 30 house so how can it be not not
in there loving my headline it's not you
won't say we'll take people working
part-time on the minimum wage out of
victim takes 30 as it was their
specified in the policy can I also ask
you what the impact of someone working
30 hours a week on minimum wage will be
in receipt of benefits and welfare
weren't there because they won't have
reached the minimum income they may well
be in receipt of benefits and what will
be the impact of your cuts in welfare on
that person well what would in work
benefits are gonna be frozen frozen so
they will still get the same amount of
money yes you can guarantee that no the
policies that will save 2 billion pounds
in welfare by freezing in work been
exactly so they'll be worse off doesn't
matter they've been taken out of income
tax because they're in real terms their
benefits going to be less well it
depends what their benefit is at any
given point just because also believe me
if you're on working 30 hours a week on
minimum wage yes you probably need
benefits you're going to freeze that you
but we're also going to but we're also
logic so that's what I mean the
implication is we're going to take you
out of income taxes we're going to give
people a minimum wage something you're
not giving them something is their
full-time they'd still be paying those
still be paying income tax if they were
being nursing if there were a hard time
they'll be having a benefit frozen would
they be paying less income take over
having the benefit frozen though we will
be paying less income tax when sick why
believe however many hours they work
what doesn't matter if you have any
benefit frozen does it yes it does
because if you're having your income tax
cut yeah then you can even lay a hand on
heart someone on minimum wage will be
better off under the Conservatives well
it depends on the individual concern but
as you just I'm afraid demonstrate he
say you don't know you can you know the
value had to me we haven't even got into
where you're going to find the twenty
billion on costed spending plans which
you've got here I know that's because
you keep interrupting and the point I
made is that yeah and if you cut
someone's income tax then they are going
to be better off nor going to life their
benefit is cut no poor frozen it depends
on how much they get in benefit but
given the how much we're going to cut
their taxes okay then I I'm own mind you
and you know how much you are going to
cut with people's benefits by what I
knew we're going to cut their taxes so
that no one who earns less than twelve
thousand five hundred pounds a part-time
person on minimum no no that's less the
amount
yeah but also some type of equates to
someone working part time on it equates
to someone working 30 hours a point
which if you've labored but which is
also happily which under our it's in a
small print I think we've described it
as that what you might describe that
small print I would describe it as in
manifesto it's not hidden away
yeah just it more in the small print all
right I just saw column in The Sunday
Times is skipped print just at just a
final question yes you've been saying
that you only need eleven thousand extra
voters to win the election problem is
that presumes are going to hold every
single one of the voters you have lost
hand round as well and then you lean on
eleven thousand but yes Lord Ashe was
polls show you're not doing that I don't
comment on polls what I do see is do you
do because you're saying we need eleven
thousand extra yes under well that's
talking about the general election not
opinion yeah do settings that's just
looking at this very very narrow pick
of the majorities which you need to
overturn if everything else remains
equal yes and I would all I want to ask
you is do you honestly believe after
five years
everything else has remained equal I
will do actually I think that things are
better I think that we'll get many more
voters than just eleven thousand extra
voters I think that we will hold all the
seats that we currently hold and win a
number of seats from other parties and
we'll have a conservative majority
government okay we will look forward to
that if indeed that's what the voters
decide thank you thank you